was geht ab hier ist und ich bin heute
hin richtig amsterdam uni bern hat eine
kleine app zocken und zwar mister jump
es ist richtig lustig und schwierig und
deshalb zog - ich bin dieser kleine mann
und wenn ich tippe kurz dann springt er
hoch wenn ich heute springt ja weiter es
ist am anfang noch relativ einfach
zumindest betreue ich mir aber anfangen
ohne abzustürzen runter zu kommen aber
ich glaube ist nicht gut ausgehen das
erste level
ich kann das ja auch schon ich habe er
die app schon mal gespielt aber ich sage
euch mann rastet aus bei diesem mit
diesem etwa dieser apps ist einfach
unglaublich
louis und und und ich glaube zumindest
mein bruder escapes anschauen das video
mit komplett ich habe das so das haus
auszog habe ich das unten am fernseher
angeschlossen bei meinem handy und dazu
die ganze zeit gesagt spiel walter
spielleiter und ok das gibt einen
zusätzlichen sprung
ok ja ich hab's ich hab's drauf leute
und zack glaube die ersten level kann
ich einfach so mitnehmen so ist es
ziemlich stürmisch und die kamera steht
direkt am fenster man vielleicht erst
mal reden und dann weiterspielen und die
kamera steht direkt am fenster deshalb
ist es vielleicht pro warten
ich dachte ich mach ich mir jetzt durch
so die ersten beiden levels erste habe
ich auch gut geschafft aber zack zack
zack aber du
so schreibt ein die kommentare / band
mark zuckerberg
weil der mann bin ich dumm ich glaub ja
so damit das ganze ein bisschen
spannender ist habe ich mir doch was tun
damit das ganze noch ein bisschen
spannender ist habe ich mir noch ein
paar fragen stellen das noch dritter die
werde ich jetzt probieren weil ihr habt
ja schon gesehen gerade multitasking
funktioniert super während ich dieses
spiel spiele welt probieren noch ein
paar fragen zu beantworten
es geht doch gar nicht ich glaube aus
zusammen mit nachbarn hoffe ich dass das
gar nicht wussten gar nicht mit nicht
einfach den zacken falsch gedacht
trinkst du gerne tomatensaft nein
eigentlich nicht
ich habe mir so ein artikel gelesen dass
tomatensaft im flugzeug besonders gut
schmeckt weil die aromen besonders stark
wahrgenommen
wo gott nicht mehr
ich marschiere durch da ist das ding
gespielt das nächste level unbegrenzte
sprünge
das klingt ziemlich doof das nutzen wir
direkt aus und probieren dabei noch eine
frage zu diesen wie finden warum man
riecht irgendwie fragen dabei was ist
ein fasching skala als christin ja ich
war für einen faschingszug bei uns und
ich würde von allen getötet weil ich
nicht groß verkleidet war
ich hatte mir einfach so eine sowie
spiel pistole mitgenommen und hatte
sonst nichts an und weil die sofern sie
außer habe ich mich halten
undercover men in black genannt weil ich
wollte nicht sagen dass ich nicht
verkleidet bin eigentlich hatte ich nur
die pistole dabei am leute abzuschießen
aber aber oder gab es eine richtige
geschichte aber das ist das ist doch das
erzähle ich nicht kurios waren wieder
als bin ich eine freundin müssen nicht -
schon im shop gewesen
nein ich bin nicht zum glas brauchen
hergekommen leute ob man es glaubt oder
nicht aber amsterdam ist echt eine
schöne stadt und man kann hier
tatsächlich andere dinge tun die auch
cool sind als gras baum aber unmöglich
das was ihr schon wieder macht wie ich
kann mir keine neue spa deutlich wie
viele spliss hast du schon durchgezogen
weil ich finde es unmöglich wie ihr mich
hier unter verdacht stellt ich gucke ist
dabei hoch uhr bog eine gute idee unter
verdacht steht dass sich drogen
konsumiere
das ist nicht der fall wer ist dein
lieblings und wer dein hass charakter
bei harry potter
also ich glaube von allen harry potter
kupfern der umstrittene us charaktere
ist am bridge die der grube das
zensieren aber jetzt nie was gehört ist
immer dieselbe stelle das schlimme bei
diesem spiel es ist wie die minecraft
jump league kommst du auch gut durch und
dann plötzlich verkaufsstudie hey ich
probiere ich nochmal unter voller
konzentration dieses level zu schaffen
kafka
teilweise ist das wie flip über das zeug
zum beispiel finde ich richtig klasse
oh ja leute da ist das ding glaube jetzt
ist es nicht mehr so schwierig und das
sieht mir schwer auf das muss ich
treffen
ok jetzt machen wir noch einen fragen
gewitter drei level finde ich ist doch
relativ gut für die leute die glauben
vielleicht darunter das schwierig wie
ein bisschen amsterdam einfach durch
nach urlaub mit meiner freundin hast du
irgendein idol wenn ja wen und warum wie
ihr bestimmt alle wisst liebe ich soll
es auch menschen da ist man ihn bis zum
rapper und ich finde einfach richtig
cool war so für ansichten vertritt und
was für musik macht ja steht ein kran in
amsterdam
hinten steht an leute ich hab die
kameraeinstellung nicht mehr hinbekommt
lieber lose abstechen oder
kindergärtnerin schwierige frage müssen
die wirtschaft in beraten bist du ein
ordentlicher mensch zimmer etc
das seht ihr was hättest du gern für ein
auto was ist ein traumauto
ja ich bin bei autos kann man sich
einiges geben also ich bin führt
natürlich irgendwelche krassen bentley
karten oder sowas fahren aber so ein cla
oder sowas fertig für den dass es von
anfang finde ich jetzt als nicht
komplett übertrieben abgehoben sonst was
ziemlich grob also ansonsten klar diese
ganzen sports autos und sonst was im
sport des sports car design sind auch
cool
die leute natürlich sagen was ist von
heute ich hoffe mal das hat alles so
hingehauen wie ich es mir vorstelle
falls nicht blöd falls doch weil die
nächsten videos werden auch so oder so
ähnlich aussehen ich bin nämlich dann in
der zweiten hälfte dieser jetzt
angefangen woche bin ich nämlich in
österreich zusammen mit esi peter und
mein bruder sk und da wird auch solche
videos geben oder blogs keine ahnung
macht's gut bis dahin tschüss